Four Seasons not gonna lie I grew up on
their music that is some damn good music
[Music]
Jersey Boys
so Jersey Boys is directed by Clint
Eastwood is the story of Frankie Valli
in the four seasons if you don't know
who they are or you don't know their
music odds are you probably actually do
know their music seriously I went to
this movie going holy [ __ ] I know a lot
of their music but I'm gonna break some
hearts and just say it's directed by
Clint Eastwood I know it sounds like a
negative and it kind of it shouldn't be
a negative but Clint Eastwood is in that
fifty-fifty margin right now he's
directed as many movies that we've
enjoyed and they've made us cry as he
has directed movies that have bored the
living [ __ ] out of us yeah he's the guy
who directed Mystic River he's also the
guy who directed Jay Edgar and that one
movie about the afterlife with Matt
Damon but this is airtight this is solid
this is a movie about the four seasons
and it has a mob element in it how can
this bore me it ain't easy apparently it
takes about 2 hours and 15 minutes but
the movies not all bad it's really not I
mean it's an interesting story and my
critiques on the movie are taking
nothing away from Frankie Valli and the
four seasons let me [ __ ] there life is
more interesting than a lot of lives but
it's all about execution Matt first of
all what is the amount of time this
movie takes place and I honestly don't
know if it's 10 years or 20 years I
think it's closer to 20 years because
his kids by the end of the movie or it's
like teenagers and with a minimal amount
of makeup on everybody just kind of
looks like everyone is frozen in time
they play young men when the movie
starts and by the end of their whole
adventure they play young men still and
there are these sections of time for
example where he's like pissed at his
wife and then all sudden he's leaving
but the kids look older now so I'm like
are you just leaving from that
conversation are you leaving five years
later what happened in the subsequent
possible five years did what were you
doing [ __ ] the performances in this
movie were all right I mean for the most
part they were functional I don't think
anyone's gonna win any Oscars for this
movie but they're not gonna get booed
off the screen that's possible a couple
of the guys will one in particular I was
like dude calm down
this one dude was just really overly
expressive with his eyes and the way he
would enunciate his words and you can
tell the dudes used to acting on stage
or something when you're acting on stage
you have to act for the people in the
back row it doesn't translate on camera
you don't have to do that when you're
being filmed
you have to act for the person who's
like a foot from you because that's
where the audience essentially is now
and they do that thing where they talk
to the audience are like yeah we were
in this we were doing this in the old
town it was like that but hey he doesn't
know that yet so let's go see what
happens that's usually fine but there
are guidelines when you're going to do
that one usually it's one person that
does it don't make multiple people do it
because just confuses people you don't
know when they're talking to someone
else or us if there's honestly a scene
frankie valli is talking and he's
walking and i'm like uh is he talking to
us i think it no he's talking to her it
fused me and do it throughout the entire
movie if you're going to do it don't do
it for half the movie and then stop
makes me feel like you were doing it
you're like as not really working out
they don't want to refilm that [ __ ] so
we're just gonna go ahead and leave it
and when they're playing their music
that you recognize you can't help but
tap your foot in that movie theater
you're like oh that is taking me back
only thing is it takes half the movie to
get there and the first half leading up
to it even though there was a mob
element and their Jersey Boys I just
sounds like it would be interesting it's
not that interesting but when the end of
the movie happened if you see the movie
you'll know I mean there's this scene
where you're like oh I feel like I'm
connecting with these guys and that's
really this is a good scene this is made
to bring in the movie up then it kept
going and I was like alright this needs
to wrap up otherwise it's gonna totally
demolish all the props it just got then
the ending kept going again and I was
like alright it's lost it's gone now so
although I like the four seasons and the
music kicks ass Jersey Boys was long it
was slow it was dull and 'next with
anybody a couple of the conflicts in the
movie were cool but not as cool as they
could have been and I walked out of the
movie going this was like Jay Edgar I
saw a life and it was not as interesting
as it probably should have been sadly if
I lose my kneecaps for this I'm sorry
but Jersey Boys ultimately you're not
gonna remember it in t-minus one day yep
already forgot it I have a theory about
that song ragdoll by the Four Seasons
everybody has a person they think about
when they listen to that song that's my
theory but so what's your favorite
oldies band we're talking bands from the
50s and 60s nope we can't go 70s where
your favorite group or song is whatever
it is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]